[Music]
nothing says summer better than an
afternoon spent chillin by the pool with
a refreshing drink in hand the issue is
that many of our favorite summer drinks
are loaded with sugars and that just
isn't what your summer bikini body needs
well I'm gonna share with you five
refreshing detox drinks which are
nutritious and will even help you to
cleanse the body giving you a flatter
tummy let's start with my favorite
watermelon and coconut infused water
watermelon is 92% water it is one of the
highest water content fruits fresh
coconut water is one of the richest
natural sources of electrolytes this
combination makes this drink extremely
hydrating and can help to reduce fatigue
and speed up muscle recovery after a
workout session I've served mine with
coconut water lots of watermelon cubes
lemon and lime slices and fresh mint
leaves this drink does not only taste
great but it also looks beautiful which
can be served as a healthy alternative
at your pool party over the typical
sugar loaded sodas green tea and lemon
detox water you must know by now that I
drink green tea and lemon water on a
daily basis well this next detox water
combines both green tea is very high in
antioxidants and can help to reduce the
accumulation of fats especially around
the belly area
lemon water aids digestion and is a
great source of vitamin C so I've served
my green tea over eyes with freshly
squeezed lemon juice sweeten it with a
little bit of honey and decorated with
some lemon slices you can drink this on
an empty stomach first thing in the
morning to get your digestive system
moving and to prevent constipation
barley mint detox water
I grew up drinking barley water almost
on a daily basis consuming barley on a
regular basis keeps your colon and
intestines happy and strengthens the
immune system simply cook about quarter
cup of pur barley with three cups of
water
tabali is tender for about 30 minutes
I served mine over eyes with barley
water fresh mint leaves and sweeten it
with a little bit of honey
you can even consume the whole barley
which is packed with fiber and will keep
you fuller for longer you also check out
my body recipes which you can make for
breakfast lunch and dinner lemongrass is
one of the most common herbs used in
Asian cooking thanks to its citrusy
aroma and health benefits it soothes the
stomach and keeping your belly happy and
healthy I've served my lemongrass water
over ice with a handful of fresh mint
leaves a few lime slices some lemon
juice and also sweeten it with a little
bit of honey this is a refreshing drink
which is perfect for the hot weather
plus the aroma of this drink will keep
you calm
finally coconut cucumber cooler one of
the easiest way to keep yourself
hydrated is to simply drink coconut
water in fact it's a much better option
over sports drinks without any added
sugars or artificial flavorings just
drink it on its own or make it fancy by
infusing coconut water with lime juice
lime and some cucumber slices so make
this summer a fit one by consuming these
detox waters plus you'll be pumping
plenty of vitamins and nutrients into
your body that will naturally help
reduce inflammation boost energy cleanse
the liver and promote healthy skin prep
them ahead and bring them out with you
to beat the heat make sure to snap
pictures share and tag me lemon air
which is a favorite in the comments
below do give this video a thumbs up
like this video share this video and do
subscribe to my youtube channel for a
lot more workout videos healthy recipes
and also nutritional tips all the best
and have a great summer